so so far what i've seen from the
trailers this show looks intense
it looks timely which i don't know if
everybody felt that way when you guys
were making this show so
why were you so fascinated to be a part
of this show
um i i definitely think that um we
all felt that it was timely even before
2020 came about
um just just regarding you know the
themes um
this this seemingly perfect glamorous um
superficial
happiness type of world um
and then you know starting to scratch at
that and seeing
seeing what's really going on underneath
um i loved
i loved for me personally i loved that i
was playing a character that actually
embraced
that embraces this world embraces the
conditioning
i thought that was that would be
interesting for me um
but definitely to be a part of a show
that is going to make people question
society as it is today
um a large part of it for me that's
amazing
um now were you familiar with the book
beforehand i know some people
um got to read it in high school or was
this kind of like new content for you
um so i was familiar with it didn't
read it um didn't read it back in high
school or whatever but was very familiar
with it
um and then i did you know i did the
whole cliff notes thing
you're not the only person who has said
that i'm the only person
you aren't the only person oh okay i was
like what no way
yeah i did the cliff notes and also you
know the show is
the themes are the same but it's you
know there's a quite a departure from
from the book
too what was it like being on set
because
i've heard from so many people now like
the the sets were just so
um amazing and so beautiful the sets
were
mind mind-blowing i don't even know
how they created it which it really
helped
make us feel like we were in this this
new london this different world because
you know a lot of the times it's green
screen so you have to use your
imagination which is obviously an
important part of being an actor
but to have
the outfits the sets the the amount of
people
it really elevated everyone's
performances because we felt like we
were in this
this music world
it probably ties along with it being
timely but you know
the sci-fi genre i love i love sci-fi
shows they always have a way of
predicting things that haven't happened
yet and then all of a sudden it happens
what is it about the show that you think
people will really connect with
oh um
i think people are going to really
connect with
the questions of what freedom
what freedom means what the importance
of individuality
um individuality with
with the awareness of of of our oneness
um i think it's also going to resonate
in a way where you know people are going
to question
what's what's important and is it
is your is happiness consistent
happiness i mean for me i think pain is
necessary to have a meaningful life so i
think it's just
you know i'm sort of just going off now
are you kidding me this is great
no this is awesome i agree with you yeah
yeah i think i think it's just going to
raise questions of of awakening and
and raise questions of self-discovery
who am i really and how can i make make
my life a little bit more meaningful
um you've been quite busy with all the
projects that you've been working on
um you're part of second season of
twilight zone what was it like working
on that show
oh my gosh so cool yeah two two
sci-fi projects yeah i like it
um oh that was amazing working with
topher topper grace
i mean yeah that was i actually shot
that in vancouver
which is my favorite place to to film
oh um and uh yeah i mean that was
that was an interesting situation i
loved it
um you know with everything going on the
world right now being a part of a show
like
when they see us must have just had such
an impact on you what was it like
you know that experience for you working
on working on that
um working on when they see us
it sorry it makes me emotional even
thinking about it just because of
everything that's going on right now
you know you know um what an
absolute privilege it was to be a part
of something
so impactful so important um
getting the chance to meet the men
themselves
who um i will be forever grateful
to have been a part of i'm sure like
that and for eva tube given me the
chance to play a real person
you know yeah um yeah that that
that one that one changed me you know
i've seen on social media that you are
definitely supporting
the black lives matter movement you post
a picture of you at a protest what has
that experience been like for you
i mean what what we're seeing right now
is the effects
of the real history of america
and um people are
finally starting to wake up to the
systemic racism
to to the oppression
and in that way thank god for technology
because that's why the whole world knows
about it
and for me i mean it's it's been
interesting because i am i
am biracial but yeah the world i am a
black woman
and i it is in i feel my ancestors and
my bones and it is important for me to
stand
up for these victims
for for black people
for indigenous people for people who
have been
um wronged for hundreds of years
and so it feels good to be a part of
something
but it doesn't matter about it for me
i'm experiencing a lot of trauma and a
lot of pain
regarding how many people are being
taken from
us it's it's difficult
well thank you so much for being so
honest and for answering that question i
i
i it's a yeah it's obviously something
very challenging to talk about but i
really appreciate the work you're doing
and and thank you so much
thank you so much
you